The answer is yes there is a problem. And, and the
problem is that the before the last processor, the last processor
guy comes and sets the cone back up to N. And
remember what the last processor is doing, decrementing the count. And
if the count is zero, as soon as there is decrement
of the count and the count is bigger than zero the
other guys are sitting here. They're going to go off on their
merry way, executing code towards the next barrier. And the last
processor is, in the meanwhile, fitting the count backup
to N. But before the last processor sets the
count back up to N, the other processors may
race to the next barrier. And they may go through,
because they may find that this count has not
been set to N, yet. And they will find
that the count is zero, and then they'll fall
through. And that can be a, another happy situation. Right?